twenty-five-year-old Ricardo is not a
criminal he's not a rapist and he's
never sold drugs a day in his life he's
a college graduate immigrant rights
activist and a cancer survivor
he's also undocumented with temporary
legal status under deferred action for
childhood arrivals a program better
known as daca this is his story
[Music]
when I came here to the US I came with
my two younger sisters first and my
father my mother met us here a week
later we came with a friend of a family
it was very scary as a nine year old
taking care of your two sisters
Ricardo came to the u.s. from Mexico in
2001 when he was 9 years old
he quickly became a standout football
player in the Phoenix area earning
recognition and full-ride scholarships
to several universities but his legal
status derailed those athletic dreams
loosing a scholarship at the end of my
high school years was very shocking and
kind of painful the first indication
that we no document it was more than I
thought
his life changed again in 2012
that's when President Obama signed an
executive action establishing daca it
gave young immigrants brought to the US
illegally as children temporary
protection against deportation it also
gave them work permits I was able to get
a job work full time like my family get
a driver's license it was a huge
opportunity just to be able to drive
safe without fear I've graduated from
Arizona State University thank sadaqa
there are more than 750,000 daca
recipients in the US but it's not a
permanent legal status daca recipients
have to renew their permits every two
years during the presidential campaign
President Trump promised to end the
program so far he hasn't done that but
he hasn't ruled it out either no
election I was pretty tough having a
discussion with my parents here at home
was one of the most difficult decisions
you know in conversations and decisions
because we decided to be here is to stay
here we're a community of dreamers of
undocumented folks ready to fight back
ready to gain our dignity through our
organization through our activism right
that's our collective story that's our
us
Ricardo now works for neighborhood
ministries a Christian nonprofit in
Phoenix he hopes to increase the
political representation of Latinos in
Arizona we're doing a lot of community
organizing around voter registration
that creates an opportunity for our
community to be part of this issue
making process in Arizona and also
hiding anti immigration a lost rhetoric
environment two years ago Ricardo was
facing another battle this time it was
life and death when I was 23 I went to
the doctor I had a mass growing on my
bottom lip area and they did removal of
the mass and and sure enough we found
out that it was it was cancer even while
undergoing cancer treatment he continued
community organizing helping to educate
voters about the issues in the 2016
election his cancer is now in remission
I think when we get to the difficult
time with constant contact with my
family families like ours is gonna
they're gonna fight they're gonna
they're gonna continue to be resilient
they're gonna continue to be hopeful
because that's the reason why we came in
the first place I am - buck Melissa we
were inspired to tell the stories of
undocumented immigrant workers here in
America their fathers mothers students
and people make a difference with their
hard work we start our series with the
farmworkers who bring food to our tables